this hour is so special to me it's not
just funny you know I'm speaking a lot
of stuff from the heart
um and so I was a little nervous about
shooting that because I wanted it I
wanted to really connect with that
emotionally and it's also
um not something that I usually do like
when I first did my specials I just I
was like I just want to be funny I don't
care you know people always like you
know yeah but what are you really
talking about it's like I'm talking
about how messed up and silly everything
is but this is the special is way
different from my my uh you know it's me
growing and it's me uh getting out there
and and and now I'm I'm now I'm in my
40s my last special I did it when I was
39 and
um yeah so I don't know it's just it
went off the first special the first
taping we did it twice the first taping
was great the second one was just one of
the best
times I did that hour so it really uh it
really means a lot that you guys came
out in Minneapolis I I love you guys I
love the support that I get uh that
everybody came out on the tour
so far I'm still doing the Don't Push Me
Tour because it hasn't come out yet the
special but like
um I just so appreciate you and this is
what I wanted to start out with this
podcast but I so appreciate you coming
through and so appreciate you supporting
me
um and I just I can't thank you enough
for for for that I really can't
um watching this the the
the Vlogs and the tour reports which I
put out there and just uh being a part
of it really genuinely means the world
to me and I know I talk a lot about you
know silly stuff on this podcast but uh
that's that's what's up and uh I really
I am so fortunate and thankful that you
guys come out to see me and I love you
for it and I try to always give you guys
the best show that I possibly can uh
which is also why I have to I have to
start writing new material now again but
yeah I love it anyway dude uh let's be
silly you know I know I know I know you
like also when I'm when I'm transparent
and all that stuff but let's be silly
too
um I don't have a title yet I I'm
circling on what the titles are will
might maybe be uh but I don't know and
when I drop it I drop the trailer it's
gonna go gangbusters go dummy viral so
we'll drop the title then you know what
I mean okay I've only been performing
this hour for
eight months like I did it it was a year
so I worked I work at the clubs a little
bit to try and get new material
like it was 2021 I started doing it in
like September I would go up every now
and then with minimal material then
April came along and I booked a date in
Phoenix one of my favorite spots to do
um
and it was April 30th and then so a year
later I did
um what do you call it I did uh that I
started the I did the taping so besides
that
um it was
I took from April to like August off so
it was really from August to now I I was
doing the tour and that's a very short
time actually from
when I uh start performing to to
shooting a special it's usually like a
year or or more you know man on fire I
was touring it for so long I was so sick
of it but I didn't want to
I didn't want to do it too here's the
deal when I do the tour I don't know
when this is going to come out but when
the special comes out it
um
it comes out and I I'll I will have
to have some new materials so in essence
when I when I shoot to special I have to
then think about starting new material
Because by the time it comes out I want
to have new material and I don't want
people to who have seen this special to
see everything from their special some
Comics do that and they are lazy crazy
crazy
[Music]
you're crazy